النجم النرويجي هالاند ينشر جروحه على
السوشيال ميديا
منعه اربعه اشخاص من دخول الملاعب في
اسبانيا
الابن يتعرض لعمليه السطو
هذه الاخبار وغيرها ننقلها لكم من العربيه
رياضه اهلا بكم
نشر المهاجم النرويجي هالاند بعد مباراه
فريقه الاخيره امام برايتون نشر ستور على
انستجرام لاحذاء الخاص به لكن الهدف من
هذه الصوره هو اظهار جروح في قدميه تسبب
بها مدافع برايتون وهذه ليست للمره الاولى
التي تظهر تظهر فيها جروح على السوشيال
ميديا حيث انتشرت صورا له بعد مباراه
ايفرتون والخدوش تملا جسده بسبب الرقابه
اللصيقه التي فرضها عليها اللاعب يرمينا
في اسبانيا استدعت اصابه كريم بنزيما تدخل
جراحيا بعد مباراه ريال مدريد وراي كانو
مباشره وكان النجم الفرنسي قد تعرض لتدخل
عنيف في الدقيقه العاشره لكنه اكمل
المباراه بل واحرز هدفا بعد اللقاء نشر
البانز فيديو لطبيب النادي وهو يقوم
بخياطه مكان الاصابه في قدمه اليمنى لوقف
النزيف
نبقى في مدريد حيث قضت محكمه في العاصمه
الاسبانيه بمنع اربعه اشخاص من دخول
الملاعب بعد الاشتباه بقيامهم بتعليق دميه
لمهاجم ريال مدريد فينيسيوس جونيور
وبنتظار محاكمتهم المحتمله محكمه مدريد
قالت في بيان رسمي انه تم الافراج عنهم
بكفاله كما لفت البيان الى ان هذا الحذر
يشمل ايضا مركز تدريب ريال مدريد في شمال
شرق العاصمه الاسبانيه
شهدت الفتره الاخيره الكثير من عمليه
السطو على منازل لاعبي كره القدم اخرهم هو
جاستن كلايبرد لاعب فالنسيا وابنه نجم
الهولندي السابق باتريك وبحسب بيان للشرطه
المحليه فان لصوص سرقوا مقتنيات عديده من
ضمنها ساعات ومبالغ ماليه بقيمه 150 الف
يورو
[موسيقى]